AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
HEARING. THERE IS A MASK
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
IN THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE
MAINTAIN PROPER MASK USAGE AT
ALL TIMES. DO NOT REMOVE OR
LOWER YOUR MASK WHEN SPEAKING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION.
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED DISRUPTION.
IN LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS ANY
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES. THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT HEARINGS
PROHIBITED. THAT INCLUDES
OBSTREPEROUS- CALLS WELL WE HAVE
A QUORUM- MISTER- CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU CALL. THE
ROLL. TO ESTABLISH QUORUM QUIRK
HERE SMITH HERE ARAMBULA. THERE
CAN. MEGAN DOLLY. CRISTINA
GARCIA. HOLDEN VOEPEL.
MURATSUCHI ARAMBULA. EXCELLENT
WE HAVE A CORE THANK YOU I'LL
FINISH READING THE INTRO AND
THEN WE'LL GET TO TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
ADDITION TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY
FROM INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM.
WILL ALSO HAVE THE OPTION OF
TESTIFYING VIA PHONE LINE- WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SYSTEM THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS COULD TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND I
REPEATED IT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR THAT ACCESS CODE A REPEAT
AGAIN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR FIVE THREE FOUR SHOULD
BE AND YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. ALL
PHONE TESTIMONY WILL BE TAKEN
TOGETHER AFTER BOTH SIDES
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE PRESENTED
. IF YOU WERE CALLING AND PLEASE
ELIMINATE ANY BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
MARK DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS COLLEEN IN YOUR REMAIN
ALIVE LINE IT WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED ON
TO SPEAK. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. THREE THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH IT WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS. TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
KEEP US ALL SAFE- WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA ONE OF
WHICH IS ON CONSENT- AND ONE OF
THESE DAYS- I'LL- INTRODUCE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL WHO'S
REPLACING DEVON MATHIS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING SO WHEN HE COMES
WELL. SAY HELLO TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
FOR EACH SIDE. CAN PLEASE NOTE
THAT PHONE TESTIMONY WILL BE
COMBINED FOR BOTH THE SPORT AND
OPPOSITION RETAKEN AFTER BILL
SUPPORT NOW POSITION PRIMARY
WITNESSES HAVE TESTIFIED. ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO STATE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION. AT IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
QUORUM- WE WILL ASK I'M ASKING
FOR A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CAN I HAVE A MOTION.
GOOD- OUR QUE HAN AND VICE CHAIR
- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. I CAN THINK
POWDER ITEM ONE AB SEVEN THREE
TO WORK MOTION DO PASS TO
CONSENT CALENDAR QUIRK. IN HOT.
SMITH ARAMBULA. BAROKA HAVE.
MEGAN DOLLY. CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN VOEPEL MURATSUCHI.
SUFFICIENT OKAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL HI YOUR BILL IS ON THE
SOUTHERN LOS ANGELES OCEAN
CHEMICAL WASTE COMMUNITY
OVERSIGHT COUNCIL. ALL RIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THREE WHICH WILL ESTABLISH
THE SOUTHERNMOST SANDALS OCEAN
CHEMICAL WASTE COMMUNITY
OVERSIGHT COUNCIL I DID NOT GIVE
WITH THAT NAME- WHICH WILL
OVERSEE THE STUDY AND MITIGATION
OF CHEMICAL WASTE IN THE ST
PETER BASIN. THOSE ARE THE
OCEANS OFF LONG BEACH- PALACE
VERDES CATALINA. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SCIENTISTS FROM UC
SANTA BARBARA PUBLISHED THEIR
FINDINGS FROM A MULTI YEAR
EXAMINATION OF A SITE ON THE
OCEAN FLOOR. IN THE SAMPEDRO
BASIN. THROUGH THE USE OF
UNDERWATER SUBMERSIBLES THESE
SCIENTISTS DISCOVERED A LONG
FORGOTTEN DUMPING GROUND FOR
TOXIC WASTE INCLUDING DDT WASTE
BYPRODUCTS AND SEVERAL OTHER
WAYS CHEMICALS THAT HAVE YET TO
BE IDENTIFIED. RECENT MAPPING OF
THE SITE SURE THAT MORE THAN
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND BARRELS OF
WASTE ON THE OCEAN FLOOR MAKE
THIS SITE ONE OF THE LARGEST
SOURCES OF CONTAMINANTS IN THE
PACIFIC OCEAN. MITIGATING THE
DAMAGE FROM THE CHEMICAL WASTE
AT THIS SITE WILL BE A
COMPLICATED. MULTI YEAR EFFORT
THAT WILL REQUIRE COORDINATION
BY SCIENTISTS ACTIVISTS ELECTED
OFFICIALS. AND MULTIPLE
GOVERNMENTAL AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES. TO
PROPERLY PERFORM THIS NECESSARY
WORK THESE VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS
NEED A WAY TO COLLABORATE AND
COOPERATE THAT ALLOWS FOR
TRANSPARENCY. AND PUBLIC INPUT.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE A PUBLIC VENUE FOR THIS
COLLABORATION BY CREATING A
COUNCIL TO BRING TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDERS EXPERTS AND POLICY
MAKERS. TO OVERSEE THE STUDY AND
MITIGATION OF CHEMICAL WASTE.
OFF OUR SHORES. TESTIFYING BY
PHONE TODAY WITH ME MISTER CHAIR
IS KATHERINE PEASE WITH HEAL THE
BAY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION ARM PHONE
MODERATOR COULD WE HEAR FROM
CATHERINE PIECE. I CURRENTLY
DON'T SEE HER DIAL THERE
CATHERINE IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE LINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AND I WILL YOUR LINE. ONE
MOMENT HERE. THANKS TO HIS
SESSIONS INCLUDE OKAY. FROM A
PRETTY WIDE OPEN. THANK YOU.%
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR PARK AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
KATHERINE PEASE MAN THE DIRECTOR
OF SCIENCE AND POLICY AT HEAL
THE BAY HILL THE BAY AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO MAKING THE COASTAL
WATERS AND WATERSHED THE GREATER
LOS ANGELES FACE HEALTHY AND
CLEAN WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL ON THE
BILL. HEAL THE BAY HAS BEEN
WORKING TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
FROM DDT CONTAMINATION AT THE
WELL KNOWN PALACE VERDES SHELF
YOU BURKE ON SITE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. THE DISCOVERY OR
REDISCOVERY OF THE DEEP WATER
DUMPING OF DDT WAS A COMPLETE
SHOCK TO US DESPITE HAVING
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE FOR SO LONG
. THIS IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM
IMPACTING COASTAL RESOURCES AND
PEOPLE ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE WHO EAT
SEAFOOD FROM THIS REGION OFTEN
SUBSISTENCE ANGLERS FEEDING
THEIR FAMILIES AND AMONG OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE
AT RISK OF DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
REPRODUCTIVE HARM AND CANCERS.
WE KNOW THE ANIMALS SUCH AS FISH
AND MARINE MAMMALS. THEY MAY
INGEST TOXINS DIRECTLY OR
THROUGH THE FOOD CHAIN AND THEY
CARRY THOSE POLLUTANTS IN THEIR
BODY BODIES AS THEY TRAVEL OR
MIGRATE. EIGHTEEN IMPACT IN THE
PAST AND ARE SEEING IMPACTS TO
WILDLIFE TODAY. IT WILL TAKE A
WELL COORDINATED EFFORT BY STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM.
CURRENTLY IT IS HARD TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION AND UPDATES ON THE
ISSUE EVEN FOR A GROUP LIKE KILL
THE BAY THAT HAS SIGNIFICANT
KNOWLEDGE AND CONTACTS ON THE-
MATTER. FURTHER NO ONE AGENCY
HAS TAKEN CLEAR LEADERSHIP AND
THERE'S NO SYSTEM TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
THREE WILL EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BY CREATING A
COMMUNITY OVERSIGHT COUNCIL ON
THE DUMPING OF TOXIC PDT WASTE
IN THE DEEP OCEAN. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THREE IS A CRITICAL FIRST
STEP AN INCREASE IN
COMMUNICATION TRANSPARENCY
REBUILDING PUBLIC TRUST. AND
TACKLING THIS PROBLEM THAT HAS
REPERCUSSIONS FOR HUMAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. PUBLISHING
THE COUNCIL WILL ALLOW THE
PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDERS TO BE
INFORMED AND HAVE A VOICE. AN
ISSUE OF SUCH URGENCY
CENTRALIZED EFFORTS ARE NEEDED
TO ENSURE GOOD COMMUNICATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROGRESS ON
THIS ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH DISASTER. ELEVENTH
STRONGLY SUPPORTS EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FIFTY THREE AND WE URGE ABOUT IT
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU- WE DO NOT HAVE A
PRIMARY- WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
SO PHONE MODERATOR- PLEASE SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
LINE AND IF YOU ARE ON THE PHONE
LINE GIVES YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY IF YOU'RE
NOT PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION YOU
CAN GIVE US WHERE YOU LIVE. AND
YOUR POSITION FOR OR AGAINST A
PHONE MODERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE
DAHLE WIPE DALVIK OVER THE FALLS
. OKAY SO WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. IT'S TIME FOR
DISCUSSION GO AHEAD MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT THANK YOU MR O'DONNELL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN AND BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- AS YOU KNOW
I. REPRESENT THE PALACE VERDES
PENINSULA- AS WELL AS VIA THE
SITE OF THE ORIGINAL MONTROSE
CORPORATION THAT WAS JUST
DUMPING BARRELS AND BARRELS OF
THIS DDT PERMITTED DUMPING- OFF
THE- BEAUTIFUL COAST OF THE
PALACE VERDES PENINSULA AND SO.
YOU KNOW MY CONSTITUENTS MY
COMMUNITIES SHARE. YOUR
CONCERNS- REGARDING- THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THE DDT- BARRELS ARE
JUST SITTING ON THE BOTTOM OF
THE OCEAN FLOOR- YOU KNOW FEARS
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THIS RIGHT
AWAY I MEAN I LIKE TO GO SURFING
RIGHT NEARBY AT TO. THAT ARE
APPROPRIATELY NAMED RAT BEACH
AND THEN IN TORRANCE AND- IT-
JUST TO CONFIRM THAT THAT IT WAS
SAFE- NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF BUT
FOR MY FAMILY MY- MIGHT MY
CONSTITUENTS AND- YOU KNOW WHY.
ALL THE TESTS INDICATED THAT-
THAT THE DDT HASN'T- IT ESCAPE
TO THE LEVEL THAT IT POSES A
THREAT TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC-
STILL YET JUST THE THOUGHT OF
HAVING HUNDREDS OF BARRELS OF
DDT LYING ON THE FLOOR- IS
OBVIOUSLY UPSETTING AND
CONCERNING TO ALL OF US- MISTER
DON I WOULD APPRECIATE IT IF- IF
YOU CAN. CONSIDER DDING ME AS A
AS A JOINT AUTHORS TO HIGH UP
OF- AUTHOR AS YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND ADDING ME I KNOW
YOU DID ALL THE WORK AND- AND I
APPRECIATE TO HEAR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS- BUT- I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE- I'M
GONNA REYES WHO JUST TO CONCERN
OF MY OWN. WE REALLY. PLEASE
CONSULT WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
I AM CONCERNED THAT THERE'S NO
LEAD AGENCY AND WHILE IT'S GREAT
TO HAVE A COORDINATING COMMITTEE
. AHA WHO KNOWS WHETHER OR NOT
THIS GOES THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
WHETHER. YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO ME
WE'VE GOT THERE SHOULD BE A CORE
ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY TAKING THE
LEAD HERE. MAYBE NOT BUT- LET'S
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS AFTER WE
PASSED THE BILL. ARE ALSO ARMED.
WITH SO IF WE END UP WITH A LOT
OF AGENCIES INVOLVED. I'M
WORRIED ALL THE PAPERWORK WILL
TAKE. MONTHS OR YEARS BEFORE WE
DO SOMETHING SO I THINK THERE'S
A LOT MORE THAT WE NEED TO DO.
IT MAY BE A CONVERSATION WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IT MAY BE
ANOTHER BILL. THAT WOULD LOOK AT
IN IN MARCH OR APRIL- BUT I AM
CONCERNED THAT WE GET THIS DONE
POST HASTE. AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT THIS COUNCIL CAN DO IT. I'M
ALSO WORRIED ABOUT GET THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY PEOPLE ON THAT THAT THE
COSTS WILL APPEAR TO BE LARGE-
SO. THERE'S A VARIETY OF THINGS
AND I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU
AND YOUR WITNESS THAT THIS IS
TOP PRIORITY AND WITH MR MERITS
YOU CHEATED. EVERYONE ELSE ON
THIS COMMITTEE. THIS IS GOT TO
BE A VERY HIGH PRIORITY- DDT
COULD LAST VIRTUALLY FOREVER.
AND SO AWARE OF THIS IS THIS IS
A BIG DEAL. BOB YOU MAY CLOSE
YES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR YOUR THOUGHTS AND
CONCERNS AND CERTAINLY WILL TAKE
THEM INTO ACCOUNT AS THE BILL
MOVES TO THE PROCESS BY THE
EFFORT OF THOSE OF THE BILL AT A
MINIMUM IS TO ENSURE-
COMMUNICATION. AND BEYOND THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IT'S ABOUT
CERTAINLY PROTECTING MARINE LIFE
BUT ALSO AS WE HEARD TODAY HUMAN
LIFE PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE
SERVING LIKE MISTER MURATSUCHI
SO WITH THAT I'D SIMPLY ASK FOR
AN IPHONE. VERY GOOD. THERE
BEING NO OTHER- FOR THE
BUSINESS. MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR THE VOTE ON. R. THIS IS A
VERY WORTHY BILL. I ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE BY
SOMEONE MEMBER O'DONNELL THE
MOTION DO PASS AND BE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WORK HI SMITH.
ARAMBULA THERE CAN. MEGAN DOLLY
CRISTINA GARCIA. HOLDEN VOEPEL
MURATSUCHI ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
STAY HERE FIVE MORE MINUTES TO
SEE IF WE CAN GET THE MR VOEPEL
AND- IN THE MEANTIME I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR BEING
HERE ON GETTING THE QUORUM AND-
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION- YES IN MR
ARAMBULA WILL ADD ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVEN THIRTY TWO- THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA. FORGET
THE PROBLEM AREA. THAT'LL. YEAH
YEAH YEAH TWENTY READ ALL
THOUGHT TRYING TO OKAY WELL. ONE
OF THE ONES THAT LOOK AT ALL THE
- YEAH SEVEN FOUR YOU HAVE
PERFORMED BETTER STATE- YEAH.
YEAH NO I AGREE WITH ME WHEN I
WENT IN RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT OUR
TIME IS UP. WE WILL BE CLOSING
THE MEETING WITH BOTH MEASURES
PASSING THANK YOU.